RONALD SMITH: I wanted to
start out just by reminding
you, we've already talked about
how the tilt of the
Earth drives the seasons.
But I wanted to be sure you
were aware of the standard
definitions regarding the
tilt of the Earth.
The tilt of the Earth's axis is
23 and 1/2 degrees in the
current geologic era.
And these things like the Arctic
Circle, the Tropic of
Capricorn, the Tropic of Cancer,
and the Antarctic
Circle are based on
that tilt, right?.
So the Arctic Circle is 23 and
1/2 degrees off the Equator
[correction: north pole].,
The tropic of Cancer-- of
Capricorn is-- both tropical
lines are 23 and 1/2 degrees
off the Equator, and the
Antarctic Circle is 23 and 1/2
degrees off the South Pole.
So these really are all based
on the tilt of the Earth.
One definition of the Arctic
Circle would be that it's only
points north of there that
experience 24-hour sunlight in
summer and 24-hour hour
darkness in winter.
Has anybody been north
of the Arctic Circle?
No one?
I think you will someday.
Try to get up there.
I lived--
I taught in Norway for a year
and had a couple of
opportunities to travel
north from there.
In the summertime, I went up to
visit my wife's relatives
up in northern Norway, which
is about 69 degrees north,
just slightly north of
the Arctic Circle.
And we enjoyed spending a couple
of weeks with them, but
that's the period of time in
which there is sunlight 24
hours a day.
So the difference between night
and day is lost a little
bit, and the people
adapt to that.
I remember the first night
we were there, we were up
drinking coffee at 1 o'clock
in the morning with our
relatives, and they suggested
that we pop next door to visit
their neighbors.
And I thought that was a little
bit odd, or at least I
thought we should call before we
dropped in at 1 o'clock in
the morning.
But they said no, no,
no, they'll be up.
So we just went next door,
knocked on the door.
They were up drinking coffee,
enjoying the night.
And so we sat there in their
living room for a few hours.
And a couple of hours later,
3 o'clock AM, their little
12-year-old came back.
He'd been playing soccer with
his friends down the street.
So the day just kind of rolls
around there, and people catch
catnaps off and on
during the day.
Sometimes they sleep in the
middle of the afternoon.
But you do lose your sense of
rhythm because you don't have
the dark of the night and the
light of the day to keep your
clock going.
So that's an odd situation.
Several months after that, I
was up in-- in the month of
November, I was on an
oceanographic expedition up
north of Svalbard.
We got to 81 degrees north at
the end of November, so that
is well north of the
Arctic Circle.
And that's only a few weeks
from the winter solstice.
So in fact, there was perpetual
darkness up there.
So we were on the ship doing
our work, putting over--
taking water samples and
measuring things, and the only
light we had outside the ship
were the spotlights and the
floodlights from the
ship itself.
I was surprised, because I
thought that even north of the
Arctic Circle in the winter, I
thought if I looked south, I'd
see a glimmer, some hint
that there was a Sun.
No.
There's absolutely-- even at
noon, you'd look south, and
the southern horizon-- which
you couldn't see, but you'd
look south--
no glint, no light at all, so
just as if the Sun pretty much
doesn't exist at that point.
And again, you lose
your cycle.
So as long as we had things
to do on the ship, we were
standing regular four-hour
watches, four hours
on, four hours off.
And that had its own
kind of rhythm.
You'd catch sleep when
you were off.
But then our work ended, and we
still had four days or five
days to sail back to Norway.
And then it was really tough,
because without your work
cycle and without the day-night
cycle, you really
were lost. And people would kind
of be wandering around
the ship, eyes glazed over, not
knowing if they should be
awake or asleep.
And it's an odd kind of thing
to be north of the Arctic
Circle, really in either of the
extreme seasons, either
the winter or the summer.
So if you get a chance, get up
there and experience that
different kind of
a climate zone.
Any questions on that?
So we're going to pick up
on this seasonal theme.
And how do the seasons
work on our planet?
And I added a little
bit to this figure.
I want to depict the Earth--
there's the rotation axis,
so this is the Northern
Hemisphere and the Southern
Hemisphere, June, July, and
August compared to December,
January, February.
And remember, June, July,
and August is
Northern Hemisphere summer.
The Earth is tilted towards
the-- the North Pole is tilted
towards the Sun, so the Northern
Hemisphere receives
much more heat than the
Southern Hemisphere.
And all of the belts and zones
defining climate shift
northwards, both those in the
Southern Hemisphere and the
Northern Hemisphere.
So the band of frontal cyclones
weakens and moves
northwards.
The ITCZ moves north
of the Equator.
Frontal storms which were down
here before move up there.
And I've put in five cities
or five locations--
A, B, C, D, and E-- and
we'll talk about
those in just a minute.
So six months later--
December, January, February--
the Sun is hitting the Southern
Hemisphere more, so
all the belts and zones--
which, remember, are driven by
the Sun, differential heating
by the Sun, so it's not
surprising that they can shift
when the source of the
heating shifts--
they all shift southwards.
So let's look at these cities A,
B, and C. So the thing that
brings most of the rain to the
world would be either the ITCZ
in the tropics, which is that
convergence of trade winds and
lifting and deep convection,
or the frontal storms, the
comma clouds, the cold fronts,
the warm fronts.
So in this season, city B will
be getting rain from the ITCZ
having shifted northward to its
location, and city E in
the Southern Hemisphere will be
receiving rain from frontal
storms that have shifted
northward to its location.
So rain in cities B and E in
that season of the year.
Six months later, it's A and D
that are receiving the rain, A
because the frontal storms have
shifted southward to its
location and D because the ITCZ
has shifted southward to
its location.
So there's a rainfall
seasonality that can generally
be understood with this
kind of a cartoon.
Now, as you can imagine, it's
going to be a little more
complicated than this
because of the
continents and the mountains.
So here's an actual depiction
of the ITCZ shift.
And in the Northern Hemisphere
summer, it's located generally
along there.
In Northern Hemisphere-- in
Southern Hemisphere summer,
it's generally located there.
And it tends to shift more over
the continents than it
does over the oceans, at least
if you look at South America
and Africa.
Notice that the Equator comes
right through here.
And in both the Eastern Pacific
and the Atlantic
Oceans, the ITCZ never
actually shifts
south of the Equator.
And I think you know the reason
for that, because we
talked about this in regards
to hurricanes.
Remember, there are no
hurricanes in those two
locations, and that's because
these two continents stretch
far enough into the Southern
Hemisphere that they draw
water, cold currents up
into this region.
And by keeping that area cold,
it's no longer possible for
that area to be the center of
convection, because that's not
where you have a lot-- you have
a lot of heat from the
Sun, OK, but that's being
counteracted by these cold
currents coming up in the oceans
in those locations.
In the Indian Ocean, however,
you have an exaggerated shift
in the Intertropical
Convergence Zone.
And this is called the monsoon
effect or the monsoon region
or just the monsoon.
It is an exaggerated shift in
the ITCZ, giving strong
rainfall seasonality to that
part of the world.
The word "monsoon" comes from
an Arabic term "mausam"--
Sharif, check me on this
or look it up--
meaning simply "seasons." But it
refers, in climatology, it
refers to this exaggerated
rainfall seasonality in
southeast Asia and the Indian
Ocean due to this big shift.
Now, that shift I think is due--
most people believe is
due to having this large
continent up here, which can
heat up in the summertime and
draw air northwards and move
that convergence zone
up over the land.
And then in wintertime,
this cools down.
We saw that in the
continentality
diagram from last time.
This mass of continent
cools down.
When you get cold air over it,
that cold air sinks and
spreads out.
You get northerly winds, and it
drives the ITCZ way down to
the south here.
So the ocean currents are
playing some role in this.
The continentality is playing
some role in this.
Otherwise, you see kind of just
the shift that I had in
the earlier cartoon for the
Intertropical Convergence Zone.
This will dominate the control
of precipitation in the
tropics, and I'll be going
back over this.
For example, let's look at
Rondonia in Brazil, which is
south of the Equator.
It's somewhere in here.
And what's plotted here are
the monthly precipitation
values in millimeters.
And notice that it has a
January-- or a November,
December, January,
February maximum.
Now, be careful how you
use the language here.
This is Southern Hemisphere, so
this would be a summertime
rainfall maxima.
And we would explain this by a
shift of the Intertropical
Convergence Zone coming down
to that location in the
Southern Hemisphere summer.
And notice, it's a
gigantic effect.
July and August are very--
June and July are very dry,
whereas the summer months--
be careful, these are the summer
months-- are quite wet.
Question there?
If you look in India,
here's precip and
temperature plotted here.
Let's just look at the precip.
There's a big maximum in June,
July, and then it starts to
decrease in August
and September.
We're in the Northern Hemisphere
now, and this would
be Northern Hemisphere summer.
So this location also has
a summertime maxima in
precipitation due to the
northward shift of the
Intertropical Convergence
Zone.
So on a typical day, you'd have
deep convective clouds,
heavy precipitation,
sometimes flooding.
And that would be a typical
condition in that season of
the year due to the northward
shift of the Intertropical
Convergence Zone.
Let's look at this interesting
site--
I don't know how to say it--
Yaounde, Cameroon.
Pretty close to the Equator.
And you could probably see this
coming, couldn't you?
So we're here somewhere, and the
point is that this doesn't
just appear there and
appear there.
It actually moves
back and forth.
So if you are close to the
Equator, you are actually
going to get two rainy seasons
a year, one when the ITCZ is
moving northward past you and
the other six months later
when the ITCZ is moving back
southward past you.
So these mark the extremes of
the movement, but in between,
you're going to get, in
some cases, a double
passage of the ITCZ.
And that's what you see here,
generally kind of a double
rainfall peak due to the double
passage of the ITCZ.
You can see this in satellite
images too.
For example, here's
an image of Africa
and the Pacific Ocean.
There's the ITCZ
in one season.
And you see most of the
precip is up in here.
Here's the other season, where
there seems to be two.
Maybe there is a weak one in the
Southern Hemisphere, but
most of the precip in Africa
has shifted down in here.
And this is all cloud-free and
not getting any precipitation
at that time.
Now, the polar front
also moves.
Everything moves together.
And so in the Northern
Hemisphere summertime, the
polar front is weak, and
it moves northward.
Weak, of course, because the
pole and the Equator are
getting about the same
amount of sunlight.
Therefore, you don't have very
much of a north-south
temperature gradient, and that's
what defines the word
"front."
However, in the winter season,
polar latitudes are getting no
radiation from the Sun, the
Equator is still getting a
lot, and therefore you build up
a strong polar front, and
it moves southward to roughly
30 degrees north.
But you see it meanders a
little bit around there.
So if you looked, for example,
at Los Angeles and plotted up
its precipitation, it'll get
precipitation starting in
November, then December,
January, February, March,
decreasing into April.
This is Northern Hemisphere,
so we would call this a
wintertime precipitation.
Here's the temperature plotted
up here, so that rain is
coming in the cool season, when
the temperature is down a
little bit.
So that is a mark of this kind
of a phenomenon, where it's
getting its rain from frontal
cyclones that have moved
equatorward in the
cool season.
Here is Rome in Italy at 42
degrees north, and you have a
similar story.
There's the temperature in
red, and it's in the cool
season of the year.
We're still in the Northern
Hemisphere, so the cool season
gives the precipitation due
to frontal cyclones.
And here is Perth, Australia,
32 south.
Now, be careful.
We've got to flip everything
around here.
So the rainy season is in June,
July, and August. That
is wintertime, as you can tell,
because the temperatures
are minimum at that
time of the year.
And so that is a, in this case,
a northward shift or an
equatorward shift in the polar
front, bringing frontal
cyclones into Perth
in the wintertime.
So this all fits that picture
of shifting belts and zones
following the Sun.
Any questions on that?
Now, some of this is nicely
summarized in a diagram that
appeared in a book by
Wallace and Hobbs.
They took rainfall data from
the Northern Hemisphere and
plotted it with little clock
arrows, little clock hands.
The length of each arrow is the
degree of seasonal change
in precipitation.
So the longer the arrow, the
bigger the difference there is
between the dry season
and the wet season.
And the orientation of the arrow
tells you in what season
of the year do you get
the rainfall maximum.
And the key is over here.
So a poleward-oriented arrow,
such as these here, would have
a July 1st maximum.
That is a summertime maximum.
This is Northern Hemisphere,
so I can use the word
"summer."
And of course, now we know
what that would be.
That would be the shift of the
ITCZ northward to bring you
rainfall in the summertime.
And if we look at India, Mumbai
here or many other
places in southeast Asia,
we find those
northward-pointing arrows.
So every time you see the
northward-pointing arrows,
including some over here, that
is the northward shift of the
ITCZ reaching that location
in the summertime.
But let's look at some
other locations.
For example, in the
Mediterranean region, all the
arrows are towards the
south, which means
a wintertime maxima.
And that would be,
of course, the
cyclones, the frontal cyclones.
The polar front strengthens and
moves southwards, and then
throughout the winter, you have
storm after storm after
storm, frontal activity
that'll bring
rain to this area.
And if we go around to
California, we find something
a little like that.
The arrows are a little
bit tilted.
They're generally tilted aiming
towards the Equator,
with some lag.
But that would be called,
as I'll describe later--
California is often described
as having a Mediterranean
climate, because it has the
same kind of wintertime
precipitation that does
the Mediterranean.
So that's a pretty
handy diagram.
Now, there are some oddballs.
There are some things
in weird directions.
For example, the arrows here
pointing towards the
east, October 1.
Anyone want to make a suggestion
of why the islands
here have a fall maximum?
Hurricanes.
And so you can find exceptions
like that, where special types
of events may be the things that
bring precipitation to
the region of interest.
Questions?
So this is a reminder, to
read you something here.
These questions we're asking
about what causes the seasons,
as you might imagine, these
are old questions.
People have been asking
themselves these
questions for years.
And Herodotus was very
curious about it.
He was Greek, perhaps the first
historian, some would say.
And he spent most of
his life in Greece.
But once in his life, he
traveled down to Egypt.
And here's what he writes
about that.
"About why the Nile behaves
precisely as it does, I could
get no information from the
priests or anyone else.
What I particularly wished to
know was why the water begins
to rise at the summer solstice,
continues to do so
for 100 days, and then falls
again at the end of that
period so that it remains low
throughout the winter"-- he's
talking about the water level
in the Nile River--
"remains low throughout the
winter until the summer
solstice comes around again
in the following year.
Nobody in Egypt could give me
any explanation of this, in
spite of my constant attempts
to find out what was the
peculiar property which made
the Nile behave in the
opposite way to other rivers?"
So I'll leave it there,
but can anyone
answer Herodotus' question?
Why does the Nile behave the
opposite to other rivers?
Want to venture a guess?
Yeah.
STUDENT: In the summer months
its getting rain from the
shift of the ITCZ, whereas in
the north where he knew, the
frontal cyclones were
contributing more?
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
So when he says "other rivers,"
he's talking about
all the rivers he's ever seen
in his life, which is
generally the rivers
coming off from the
Mediterranean region.
And that's going to be mostly
wintertime due to the
southward shift of
the polar front.
The Nile, on the other hand,
actually, the water doesn't
originate from here.
The water originates
further south.
Let's go back to my little
arrow diagram.
Yeah, there it is.
So here's Herodotus spending
his life here looking at
rivers that have a wintertime
or a springtime maxima, and
now he's down in Egypt looking
at water that actually fell
down in this region.
The source of the Nile, we now
know, is up in the Horn of
Africa, over in this region,
and that has a summertime
precipitation.
So he's really--
the answer to his question then
is exactly what you said.
It's the fact that the Nile is
controlled by the water that
falls here, which is controlled
by the northward
shift of the Intertropical
Convergence Zone.
Questions on that?
So now we're going to--
oh, I want to make this one
last point about seasons.
So you being raised around
here or in North America,
these latitudes, probably think
that seasonality has a
lot to do with temperature.
And you'd be right, but that's
a narrow, parochial attitude
from where you were raised.
If you were raised in the
tropics, you would think that
seasonality has everything
to do with rainfall.
If you make a figure like this--
and I think you might
be able to do this with some of
the data that you're given
in the problem set--
if you take the 12 monthly
precip and 12 monthly
temperature points and plot
them and connect them with
lines that link them up in
chronological order, they'll
form some kind of a figure
on this temperature,
precipitation map.
And in the tropics, for sites
in the tropics, that figure
looks like this.
You get a big precipitation
seasonality, but not very much
change in temperature.
On the other hand, in
mid-latitudes, you get a big
temperature change but not much
change in precipitation.
Now, this wouldn't apply for
every mid-latitude site and
every tropical site, but
generally this is the rule,
that seasonality in the tropics
is referring to a
precipitation seasonality, a wet
season and a dry season,
whereas seasonality in mid and
high latitudes is referring
primarily to a temperature
seasonality.
So seasons mean different things
depending where you
were brought up.
So don't get caught in that when
you're talking to someone
from a different land.
So now we turn to this
question of climate
classification.
We'd like to codify
all of this.
And the way forward on this
was over 100 years ago by
Koppen, and then later others
have modified this slightly.
So there are a few different
versions of this scheme
around, but generally it's
called the Koppen climate
classification scheme.
It uses the 12 monthly
temperature and precipitation
values with thresholds to assign
each point on the Earth
to a small set of
climate zones.
And the way those thresholds are
designed is that it tries
to capture those aspects of
climatology that would control
the vegetation that grows.
So ideally, if the Koppen scheme
works, in a particular
climate zone defined by
temperature and precipitation,
you would find a particular kind
of natural vegetation,
because it's adapted to that
particular climate zone.
There are six broad
categories--
tropical, dry, temperate,
continental, polar, and
highland climates--
and then as you know already
because you're working on the
problem set, there are
subcategories under those.
And well they're
a little bit--
let's face it, they're a little
bit messy to work with.
This is a table I pulled off of
a recent published paper on
the Koppen classes.
And it may be that these
definitions are a little bit
different than the one you have
in the back of the book,
but you get the point.
That is, you define the broad
category, like the A climates,
in terms of whether the minimum
temperature is higher
than a certain value, and then
you break it down into
subcategories based, in this
case, on precipitation.
The arid climates' precipitation
annual total,
less than 10 PTH.
I don't know what that is.
But then it's subdivided
into two categories.
Desert would be the very dry
areas, and the steppe would
get a little more precipitation,
and so on.
So using the temperature and
precipitation values, you go
through and you classify each
area by its seasonal cycle and
the mean values.
And you end up with something
like this.
I think this is from your
textbook, or you have a
diagram like this in your
textbook, where the color
schemes represent the different
climate categories.
For example, the moist tropical
climates are the A
climates, Aw, Af, Am.
The dry climates, you find
they're the B climates.
You find some of them in the
desert areas here and here.
And in the desert Southwest,
you find some B
climates, and so on.
This is the Western Hemisphere,
North and South
America, and then we do
something similar to that for
Asia, Africa, and Australia as
well using the same scheme.
So it's not zonal, but you can
see zonal aspects to it.
But all of those factors that I
mentioned the other day are
working, not only the zonal
aspects of the general
circulation, but also the
mountains, the continentality,
and cool and warm ocean currents
that are bringing up
water to the coastlines
of these continents.
They're all playing
some role in this.
North America looks like this.
It's pretty simple east
of the Mississippi.
West of the Mississippi, it's
more complicated, because you
have some mountainous areas and
some contrast between wet
and dry areas.
Let's look at three cities
in North America.
Sacramento, in California,
now, that is a classic
Mediterranean climate, right?
The precip is in the
wintertime when the
temperature is down.
So Sacramento has a
Mediterranean climate, and
that would be a Csa climate
in the Koppen scheme.
New York City, close
to us, this might
as well be New Haven.
New Haven's very
much like this.
Pretty much the same rainfall
throughout the year, but a
very strong temperature
seasonality.
That's a Dfa climate.
Miami has a summertime precip
mostly from thunderstorms in
the summertime, and then Denver
is a drier climate in
general, also--
well, it's a more of
a spring maxima.
We talked about why that is.
In the springtime, you tend to
get these severe thunderstorms
that occur in that part of the
world, because you get the
right jet stream aloft and the
moist air coming in from the
Gulf of Mexico.
But that extends to some extent
throughout winter--
throughout the summer as well.
The reason why the winter is
so dry is because in the
wintertime, those storms coming
from the Pacific lose
their rain in the Rockies.
And by the time it gets to
Denver, they're pretty dry, so
you don't get much precipitation
in the
wintertime in Denver.
Let's look at Africa
for a second.
There's the Koppen scheme
for Africa.
And let's look at the Af
climates, which are the
tropical rainforest. That's this
deep blue area here, a
lot of water and dense tropical
forest vegetation.
Then if we look at the BSh
climate, which is the steppe
climate, that would be up in
here, these little golden or
yellow areas.
They get one pulse of precip
every year when the ITCZ moves
northward, and then it's dry
for the rest of the year.
So a brief rainy season
providing enough water for the
grass, but you see now
it's browned out--
well, still a little bit
green up there--
and then that rain moves back
to the Equator and then back
into the Southern Hemisphere
later on.
So that gives you the
steppe climates
of Kenya, for example.
By the way, these animals, the
wildebeests, are mobile
animals, and very often they
will travel several hundred
miles trying to follow that
shift in the ITCZ.
So they don't understand it, but
they have evolved to know
that if they move southward,
they can get a longer season
where the grass will be green,
and they can get
good eating that way.
And then you have the BWh
climate, the really dry
climates up in here.
That's the red one, the deep red
one, and of course that's
a place where it really
seldom rains in any
season of the year.
The ITCZ doesn't get that far
north, and the frontal
cyclones don't get
that far south.
So you've got this zone in
between where you've got the--
it's the descending branch of
the Hadley cell, of course--
the air is descending there,
keeping it from
precipitating--
but that's because the ITCZ
never reaches there and the
polar front never
reaches there.
It's this dry area in between.
Questions there?
India.
Let's take a look at Europe,
for example.
I want to get back on
this issue of the
Mediterranean climate.
This yellowish is
the Csa climate.
You see it all along the coast,
north and south coast
of the Mediterranean, and that's
why that is called a
Mediterranean climate.
Whoops.
And so when you look
at Lisbon in Spain
[correction: Portugal], it has
that characteristic of a
cool-season precipitation.
If you look at Jerusalem, it has
the characteristic of the
cool-season precipitation.
Cairo, the same thing.
So, you know, that's a pretty
common-- that's a uniform
climate zone.
And then I've already shown you
this, but switch over to
Sacramento.
Well, it looks just the same.
So that's why we say Southern
California has a Mediterranean
climate, because it fits that
general picture from the
Mediterranean.
And again, I've said this enough
times, but this one is
due to the southward shift of
the polar front and the rain
that comes in frontal
cyclones.
Questions?
Let's look at, let me--
I think we're close
to the end here.
We may finish a few
minutes early.
That'd be nice.
Let's look at a couple little
additional examples of
seasonality.
Here's a couple of satellite
images taken from North
America-- from South America,
where the Maranon and the
Ucayali join to form
the Amazon.
And at the end of the rainy
season, those rivers are
pretty swollen.
Every place you see blue,
that's water.
But at the end of the dry
season, the flow in those
rivers is very much reduced.
And what the purple color here
is are those dry sand banks on
the side of the river.
Because the river is now lower
and moving much more slowly,
you have barren, unvegetated
areas.
And of course, this has been
meandering through time.
On the field trip the other day,
we were talking about how
that meandering river has
flattened out the Quinnipiac
salt marsh.
Well, you see here, everywhere
you look, old places where
that river used to be.
So that's been meandering back
and forth over geologic time,
leaving all these little
remnants of
meanders in the river.
And most of that erosion takes
place in the wet season, when
the flow of the rivers
is high.
Here in New England, the Dfa
climate, as I mentioned, it's
a temperature seasonality,
rather than a
precipitation one.
And so the summertimes look like
this, with the deciduous
trees being out.
Then they drop their leaves, and
it gets very cold and the
snow falls, such as
you see there.
I put together a little set of
satellite images here to make
another point about New
England's seasonality.
Looking down from a satellite,
you can map out the
distribution of vegetation using
something called NDVI.
It's the Normalized Difference
Vegetation Index.
It's the ratio of the
reflectivities in two
different visible bands.
Oh, sorry.
It's the ratio of the
reflectivity in the
near-infrared to the red.
It turns out that vegetation has
a very strong signature if
you look at those two bands.
So here's four months, April,
June, August, and November.
Now, as you first glance at
that, you may say, well, they
look a lot alike.
And I guess they do.
But I'm going to take some
differences between these
plots to try to bring out how
things have changed with
season, how the vegetation
has changed with season.
And that's shown in the
next plot here.
In this one, I'm calling it a
leaf-out index, because I've
taken the June NDVI and
subtracted it from April.
So I'm finding how much the
vegetation has changed from
April into June.
Well now, if you've lived in New
England at all, you know
that the big event between April
and June is the leaf-out
of the deciduous trees.
Usually that happens in mid-May
here in Connecticut.
And so when I take this
difference, what I'm mostly
going to be seeing is the
distribution of deciduous
trees-- oaks, maples, and so
on-- and that's what we see.
So the seasonality in New
England, while it is--
at its root it's a temperature
seasonality, it also has a big
impact on the vegetation.
Leaf-on, leaf-off controlled by
that temperature, and you
can see it from space.
Now, in areas where there hasn't
been much change, those
might be conifers.
They look about the same in
the winter and summer.
Or they might be barren areas,
where there's no vegetation in
either season.
Is that clear what
I've done there?
I've subtracted the
NDVI of April--
June minus April to get the
difference in vegetation.
And in this case, it's going to
show me where the deciduous
trees have leafed out because
of the seasonality.
I'm going to do the same trick
now for August minus June to
see how vegetation has changed
over the summer.
And you see these little pockets
of red are where
there's a big positive change,
where there's much more
vegetation in August
than in June.
And I'm calling that the growing
season, because what
that's going to do is pick
out the agriculture.
Farming in this part
of the world is
usually a summer activity.
You plow and plant in the
spring, and then your crops
grow-- your corn or your wheat
or whatever grow over the
summer months, and you harvest
in August, September, October.
So this difference between those
two months is largely
going to be a measure of where
agriculture remains.
There's not much left in New
England, but we can see
exactly where it is.
There's quite a bit of
agriculture in western New
York State near the
Finger Lakes.
There's some in the very upper
Hudson Valley and up into
Canada around Montreal.
There's quite a bit down here
in eastern Pennsylvania.
Those are the Amish farms
growing their crops down in
eastern Pennsylvania.
A little bit in Connecticut
up around Springfield in
Massachusetts.
And some places in Connecticut
you find some agriculture.
But again, this is seasonally
driven.
So human activity here is
being driven by the
seasonality and ultimately which
goes back to the tilt of
the Earth's axis.
Any questions on this?
Now, another aspect of
seasonality for New England--
and this is particularly timely,
because we were just
out on the river
the other day.
So I've already told you-- and
I've shown you, in fact-- that
New England gets about the same
precipitation in every
month of the year.
Why is it then if I look at the
daily discharge data from
the Quinnipiac or most other
rivers that there is a
seasonal cycle to it?
More discharge in the winter,
less in the summer, June,
July, and August. Winter, less
in the summer, June, July,
August. It didn't drop quite as
much in the summer of 2006,
but then it dropped even more
in the summer of 2007.
This is a log scale, so this is
a very significant change.
This is an order of magnitude
difference.
Look, this is 200 to 300 to 400
cubic feet per second down
to, well, 60 or 70 cubic feet
per second down there.
So a gigantic seasonality
in the river flow
and yet not the rain.
What's going on there?
You've got to tell
me this one.
Somebody tell me this.
STUDENT: The snow melting?
PROFESSOR: Part of it, but not in the
Quinnipiac.
That would explain some of the
rivers further north in New
England, but the Quinnipiac
doesn't get much snow.
It's down here in Connecticut,
so that wouldn't explain it.
We need another explanation
for this.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Evaporation.
PROFESSOR: Evaporation.
So remember, evaporation is--
(a), it's very strongly
controlled by temperature, and
since New England has a
temperature seasonality,
you're going to get a big
seasonality in evaporation.
Also, from the trees.
The deciduous trees evaporate
water from their leaves.
As soon as the leaves fall
off, you don't get that
so-called evapotranspiration.
So that's a big seasonal
cycle.
So during the wintertime, most
of the rain that falls ends up
in the rivers.
During the summertime, most
of the rain that falls
evaporates, and much
less flows down the
river to the sea.
So here's the question.
Does New England have
a wet-dry season?
Well, that depends on how you
define it, doesn't it?
Because it doesn't have much
of a seasonal variation in
precipitation, and yet it's got
a strong seasonality in
the amount of water in the
rivers because of the
evaporation effect.
Questions on that?
And I think that's the last
one, almost the last one.
So I took a couple of satellite
images from Alaska,
one in June and one
in November.
And June, early summer, there's
still a lot of snow
cover from the previous year.
The melting has begun there, but
it takes several months of
warm conditions before you get
rid of most of that snow.
So you see snow, a little
bit of barren land,
some water out here.
In November, next month,
it looks so different.
Well, part of that is because
there happened to be more
clouds on that day, but I wanted
to make a couple of
other points.
There's actually less snow then
than there was earlier,
because the snowfall
is just beginning.
But here's the thing I wanted to
show you that intrigued me.
I hope you can see that
from the back.
There's a curious little line,
a little dark-light contrast
right there.
And that is evidence of
the low Sun angle.
Remember, in this season of
the year in Alaska, high
latitudes, the local solar
zenith angle is going to be
quite large.
That Sun is slanting in
at a very low angle.
And that little line I'm seeing
there is the shadow of
this mountain range cast across
the valley onto the
facing slope.
So not too relevant for
climatology, I grant you, but
a reminder that the Sun angle
is very low at that season.
And that itself, I guess, is
a kind of seasonality.
If you lived down in this
valley, you wouldn't see any
sunlight in the wintertime, but
you might in the summer
when the Sun's higher
in the sky.
But then you'd have snow at that
earlier part of the year.
And then just to remind you that
it's not just this smooth
cycle of the seasons that
matters, but it's the events
that can also matter and would
be normally considered to be
part of the climatology.
For example, hurricanes, which
are discrete events, and you
may not even get one in any
particular year, but still,
they occur in the late summer or
fall in either hemisphere.
Severe Oklahoma thunderstorms
are a springtime phenomenon.
Nor'easters in New England
are wintertime.
California fires are primarily
in the fall.
Antarctic ozone hole--
we'll discuss that later
in the course--
occurs in October.
And El Nino when it starts up--
we'll discuss this too--
usually starts up in December.
So it's not just a smooth cycle
of the seasons, but it's
the way the seasons control
events that can be quite
important as well.
Any questions on this or
anything else about
seasonality?
I think that's it today.